what's the story hopper
what's this you're teaching us sifting
through the bullcrap because there's
been so much what's the truth now hopper
do you think it's worth the love fixing
revisionist history from all your school
tech bird get the soup now hopper
victimized and they're sifting out the
[ __ ] it's Harper on the trail come
on harbor what's the Sony Harper what so
he hovered catch the [ __ ] in Harper
the word separation of church and state
have turned into a colloquialism often
incorrectly being attributed to the
Constitution directly where the words
never actually appeared no the words
were originally written in a private
letter from Thomas Jefferson to the
Danbury Baptists in 1802 specifically
responding to a letter of theirs
expressing concern regarding a state
enforced denomination sir
among the many million in America and
Europe who rejoice in your election to
office we embrace the first opportunity
which we have enjoyed in our collective
capacity since your inauguration to
express our great satisfaction in your
appointment to the chief magistrate of
the United States and though our mode of
expression may be less courtly and
pompous than what many others close
their addresses with we beg you sir to
believe that none are more sincere our
sentiments are uniformly on the side of
religious liberty that religion is at
all times and places a matter between
God and individuals that no man ought to
suffer in named person or affects on
account of his religious opinions it is
not to be wondered at therefore if those
who seek after power and gain under the
pretense of government and religion
should reproach their fellow men should
reproach their order magistrate as an
enemy of religion law and good order
because he will not dare not assume the
prerogatives of Jehovah and make no laws
to govern the kingdom of Christ
you see with a new nation just having
escaped the oppressive thumb of the
Church of England the Danbury Baptists
were naturally fearful of the government
corruption of personal religion a fear
which President Jefferson specifically
quelled gentlemen the affectionate
sentiments of esteem and uh probation
which you are so good as to express
toward me on behalf of the Danbury
Baptist Association give me the highest
satisfaction easy message don't bother
me I'm busy apologies we're living with
you that religion is a matter which lies
solely between a man and his God that he
owes account to none other for his faith
in his worship at the legitimate powers
of government reached actions only and
not opinion I contemplate with sovereign
reverence the act of the whole American
people which declared that the
legislature should make no law
respecting an establishment of religion
or prohibiting the free exercise thereof
the building a wall of separation
between church and state see Jefferson
was expressing that the government would
stay out of the business of running
churches because he personally deeply
valued faith even its impact on
government and understood that
government organized religion would
actually be corrosive toward it
basically don't worry we are never going
to be like those I maze at Church of
England those guys that did
digs this was often confused with the
notion that President Jefferson wanted
Christian principles kept out of
government which is far from the truth
considering that Jefferson was a man of
deep faith himself and practiced it even
in the way he closed this very formal
letter I was super Kate your kind
prayers for the protection and blessing
of the common father and creator of man
and tender you for yourselves and your
religious Association assurances of my
high respect and esteem Thomas Jefferson
January 1st 1802 y'all said mr.
Jefferson sir
I said Oh bother me I say it almost all
don't know
oh I said don't bother me I meant it
girl
sound of flesh okay strange individual
catch the [ __ ] hop all the faster if
you like this clip it's taken from the
fold Daily Show available exclusively a
lot of credit calm / mug Club that's for
mug Club members because we can't be
dependent here in the Google YouTube
overlords subscribe there we have a
daily show full hour every day if you
don't well there's no saving you